Cool coffee beans,
you've made your first app, but
don't take my word for it.
Make sure that it runs on your phone.
So now I've taken you through three
steps to show you how to take a drawing
to an app.
Let's recap a little.
The first step was to choose your views.
A great place to start with this step
is to circle the different views.
And then decide which view
tags you need to use.
Katebin Kanal taught you about two
view tags, imagery and text views.
And they also mentioned
a view called a button,
which we'll be using in the next lesson.
As you begin to feel
a little bit more ambitious,
you can discover new views
in the documentation.
All right once you're done choosing
your view, you move on to positioning.
And the question you need to be
asking yourself at this stage is what
view group should I use.
Now, view groups have a lot
of control over how and
where you position your views.
If the views are aligned horizontally or
vertically,
you probably want to
use a linear layout.
And if the views are aligned
relative to one another,
then you probably want to
use a relative layout.
Now once you're made this decision,
if you're using a linear layout,
you're going to think about things
like orientation and layout weight.
Layout weight in particular is a little
bit complicated but pretty powerful.
It allows you to sort of equally
distribute your views across the screen
which is a really great feature.
If you're using a relative layout,
you'll will be thinking of how to
position your views relative to their
sibling views, and to their parent view.
Now, this will be done using
the align parent attributes, and
attributes like to left of and
to right of.
Step three is the fun step,
where you get to style your views.
During this step you'll look at things
like the text, and the color, and
the font, and
decide what you want them to look like.
Will the text have a background color,
how will the pictures
fill up their space?
Once you know the attributes
you're going to change,
then you need to now the correct
value you're going to change them to.
Finally, you'll look at the more subtle
spacing issues between elements.
And you can tweak the spacing
between elements using padding and
layout margin attributes.
Once you're able to master these steps,
you should be able to take any
simple drawing that you come up with,
and turn it into an Android app layout.
Good work.